[Musique]
mes amis je pense que la tour
montparnasse n'a pas besoin de nos
maigres se couvre pour répéter qu'elle
existe tout paris s'en est aperçu et
disons le entre nous tout paris à penser
que la tour montparnasse écrasé paris il
fallait des visions ou rendre compte si
c'était vrai mais le meilleur moyen de
nous en rendre compte ce n'était pas
très honnête c'était du lavoir et de
monter dessus mais renvoi d'ascenseur
c'est le cas de le dire cinquante huit
étapes et nous voilà au sommet de la
tour montparnasse mimétisme curieux de
l'occupation romaine vous savez bien
cette colline à rome même 8/10 les
contradicteurs et je trouve cette
colline à paris aussi à paris voyez-vous
s'est aligné sur romu qu'il a fait
j'aperçois le le mont valérien il faut
bien saluer le mont valérien
car je disais écrasé par paris nous
sommes ce livre d'image considérable
le mont valérien il faut le saluer quand
même on commence par lui
je sais bien que ce n'est pas dans les
normes romaine parce que là nous parlons
urbi et orbi
je me tourne comme ça tout doucement
vers douvres une autre colline c'est
chaillot chariot c'est un caillou il ya
le palais de chaillot
ça aurait dû être vous le savez le
palais du roi de rome mais napoléon 1er
est mort trop tôt et leurs hommes
étaient d'ailleurs occupées en autriche
j'ai oublié la tour eiffel si vous
saviez vous savez je n'ai pas souvent
aimé et je la trouve fort belle c'est
une vieille dame et vous savez qu'il ya
beaucoup d' à lui 1
hélas comme des bijoux sur son col et
sur sa poitrine et voyez vous lorsqu'on
est dans paris la tour montparnasse a
l'air de s'être déposé là d'une façon
asymétrique et bien nous nous avons
révolutionné le tout nous sommes dans
l'arc ce de la tour eiffel
la grande dame que je
à lui après l'avoir tant maudite à il
faut aller quelquefois résipiscence
minutes 2-2 de colline à 3 calling
voyons trois collines alors ça va me
conduire
je suis obligé d'arriver à montmartre oh
mon dieu lui ou lui aussi le sacré coeur
c'est à vous de juger
le sacré coeur d'un certaine abadie
monture habituelle voir alors par son
bras colline quatrième colline le monde
le mont chauve les buttes chaumont
ça ça doit être le père lachaise par là
car c'était une colline de paris cédant
la direction de ménilmontant nous
pourrions gravir la rue du télégraphe au
père lachaise infirmière de tout à
l'heure ça avait de l'importance dans un
autre temps et puis il yal le gibet
comme ça fait collins a5 déjà je crois
que je vais arriver au bout du compte un
et je tourne où il ya encore à je suis
assis je crois elle me manque sept
collines n'arrive pas je ne voyais pas
mais voyons je vois le panthéon pauvre
soufflot ça vous a coûté cher
l'avis de même le panthéon mais l'amour
ma 7e collines et les là devant c'est la
butte aux cailles n'y est plus je vois
des chandelles des chandelles des
chandelles des chandelles pauvre marquis
d'arlempdes quand vous partiez de saint
cloud avec votre montgolfières de la
paille et du ce vous avez survolé le
premier pari mais vous avez vous avez
atterri tout simplement là vous ne
pourriez plus aujourd'hui regardez ces
collines général nous sommes ou déposer
des monuments bien paris je ne peux pas
passer tous les monuments revue ya
environ quinze monuments nationaux sur
les 15 il y en a mais ton six ou sept
ans remarquable c'est à vous de me dire
lesquels
pour ne pas être là alors comme je ne
peux pas faire de discrimination je vais
saluer le plus beau je salue les
invalides le cimetière montparnasse à
mes pieds
le fait venir sur les lèvres un vers de
baudelaire
je quitterai quant à moi satisfait un
monde où l'action n'est pas la soeur du
rêve et quand je vous disais tout à
l'heure je reviendrai au père lachaise
cudi rastignac d'aujourd'hui car tu doit
bien exister rastignac tu gravissait les
pentes du père lachaise
tu ne pourrez plus dire à nous deux
paris qui cassera les dents
[Musique]